how does a writer create an emotional
core for their story where the audience
will
relate and go on the journey and feel
the ups and downs
um well i usually talk about the
emotional core
as being sort of a combination of four
components
actually five so there's another fifth
stealth element
here um so the four that i think um
are involved are the things that
basically the character has to
prioritize
over the course of the story and the way
they
prioritize those things sort of the
change in their priorities
shows us the effect that the plot events
have had on them if that makes sense
so they start out
in a status quo so they have a we're
just going to get real technical with it
so they start out with an inner drive so
some some sort of inner motivation
that's um causing them to uh
that sort of i take that back that's
that's motivating their
actions in life right i'll use my
favorite example so in die hard
um john mclean shows up on page one
wanting to fix his marriage that's
what's driving him internally so
we know that he has come to la he wants
to
bring his wife back to new york their
marriage has been
sort of struggling whatever so we know
that that's what's driving him
internally
he also has a misbehavior so some people
call this a character flaw
i like to call it a misbehavior because
uh i don't think it has to be
objectively negative right so it's a
it's a behavior that isn't serving them
as well as they think it is or it's some
strategy that they're using
in order to pursue that inner motivation
right so he shows up on page one wanting
to
um fix his marriage and the strategy
that he's using for that
is by being macho and uncompromising
right so he's basically a caveman when
he shows up he's like
i'm gonna take my wife and drag her back
to new york with me right
that's kind of his attitude when he
shows up so those are the first two
elements that's kind of the character
status quote right what's motivating
them internally and
the the way they're going about getting
it which is really their defining
characteristic it's their misbehavior
right
uh and then the other two things are the
stakes and and the goal and we've
already talked about those so you know
what those are very well
so those four things are in play
um they're they're put in play basically
in the setup of your story right so he
shows up on page one
wanting to fix his marriage the way he's
going about it is
by being macho and uncompromising uh
over the course of act one
terrorists show up and he forms the
story goal of needing to save those
hostages
from the terrorists right and one of the
hostages is his wife
so that's his story goal what's at stake
the lives of the hostages
including his wife right he really wants
to save his wife's life
obviously because that goes to uh fixing
his marriage
so those four things these are his
priorities when we have completed our
setup
as we watch the movie uh and his pursuit
of that goal and all of the things that
are
happening to him as he pursues the goal
all of the complications and obstacles
and that main force of antagonism
those things and his um the the
plot events that he's um encountering
are forcing him to re-prioritize
now die hard is is a slightly
rare example because um he he isn't
necessarily forced to reprioritize by
his interaction with the terrorists
but because he goes through this whole
experience of
potentially losing his wife right she
might die he might die
they may never be able to get back
together and make it work right
because that's hanging in the balance he
is forced to have sort of this like
come to jesus moment where he's like i
have been doing things wrong
he says to his cop buddy on the outside
like if i ever get out of here or if i
don't get out of here
tell my wife that i was wrong or that i
should have done things differently or
something like that i can't remember the
exact dialogue but
he has that moment where he admits that
he has been
going about things the wrong way because
he thought he knew the right way he
didn't give her enough credit
right so he continues through the rest
of the plot and then by the end of the
movie we see how he has prioritized
those four things so
he has managed to save the hostages so
he's accomplished the goal
he has protected his stakes because he
has saved the lives of those hostages
including his wife
um he is going to be able to fix his
marriage we get the sense right because
his wife
and he have that like moment at the end
um where they're working together
right and then his uh his misbehavior
is the last thing that's that's left
that could potentially change and so
by the end of the movie this may be my
interpretation but i think that he has
come to realize that he cannot
treat his wife like he's a caveman and
he's macho and uncompromising anymore he
has to take her needs into account too
her input she's a smart lady she's
clearly like had this whole career that
she didn't need him for right so they're
more equals than he thought he doesn't
have to protect her all the time
he can let her be a part of their
marriage they can be a partnership
so he has re he has reprioritized those
four things and really what i mean by
that is he's
he's sort of like you know let go a
little bit of the machoness
in order to get the other things saving
his marriage
you know um uh saving the hostages
um basically that's it saving the
hostages and protecting their lives
right
so the way he re-prioritizes those
things
shows us the uh emotional arc and the
character arc right
now we know how he's changed we know
that he started out thinking he had to
be this macho protector
and by the end he knows that he can
actually allow his wife to be
a real partner in their marriage and
they can work together
and right off into the sunset together
does that make sense yes it does
wow that's excellent i don't even
remember what my initial question was
because i'm like
still thinking about the movie and
right right and how he softens a little
bit has a little more humor to it right
right and die hard is a big action movie
so it's not like he's gonna have this
you know profound like internal change
where he goes from being
macho to being just a pussycat who's you
know not going to stand up to anyone
it's not going to be that kind of like
180 change
but we do see that he has re-prioritized
those four things and that's what the
question was which
was about the emotional core so that's
what the emotional core
it's just a term that i use to sort of
encapsulate the
character arc and the emotional journey
and kind of the um the takeaway message
of the theme
all in one because that's really when we
see that character go through this
experience and have this
particular change or adjustment in
attitude
that tells us that gives us the lesson
of the theme it tells us what's
important
that we need to know about how to live a
better life or be a better person or
whatever
and if we look at the stakes too it's
not just the terrorists but then
the aren't they like in a very high
point on the building
yeah just be like the arco building or
whatever the highest one in l.a yeah and
so
there's the stakes of that how are they
going to
access this level and there's different
you know they're going in the stairwells
and things like that so that's
the nakatomi building oh okay sorry no
in the movie in the movie
okay right okay um in it's in century
city um
but yeah so the stakes well so the
stakes are really the
the life of the hostages right including
john mclean's wife so that's that's what
he's trying to save and then he's
he we talked about um stakes and
sacrifice he is sacrificing his own
safety
in order to protect those stakes right
which is
you know again story nerd stuff but
valuable to think about because it's
like
if he was going to risk his life to
get his wife out of a parking ticket
we'd be like that's
i'm not i'm not on board with the story
people would check out they'd stop
reading
stop watching the movie or whatever
right so the the stakes and the
sacrifice have to really balance we have
to understand
how how they warrant each other
essentially
you know well you see a story in order
like it's like it's a bad thing or you
have to apologize
wouldn't doesn't someone have to really
be a story nerd
to write well because if you're too cool
for story
then you're gonna ignore a lot of the
details
and a lot of this parts of this engine
correct yeah well i mean
thank you for saying that no i i think
so
um so i like
thinking about kind of the the theory of
how
you know how stories work and all the
parts and i
that's my favorite thing that's why i do
what i do
but i actually think that um i mean yes
is it valuable for writers to understand
definitely
um i don't think everyone is as nerdy
about it as i am
but so and and i don't think that's a
problem uh i do think
a lot of writers come at their stories
sort of instinctively and intuitively
and you know we all have kind of that
sense of a story right like we all
understand beginning middle and end
and um we we've had that ingrained in us
since we're kids and so i think
i think a lot of writers don't need to
understand kind of the minutia
of all of this stuff as much as as much
as i enjoy talking about it
um because they come at their stories
instinctively and they just have a story
they want to tell and
it can you know they can get it on the
page without
thinking about stakes or you know
sacrifice maybe
um on the first pass right but where i
where i do think it will come in handy
is if um
if you are struggling to make a story
work or
several screenplays work right if you're
kind of running into the same problems
over and over
then i think it's super valuable to look
at what is it that i
am instinctively not getting right
where is that thing happening that's
that's not allowing my story to work as
well as it could
uh and then that's maybe the the part of
the story nerd
canon to dive into um just figuring out
like
what is the thing that uh i'm not
automatically bringing to the page
and and you know sort of like
understanding that part of it a little
bit better and maybe honing those skills
so then the story nerd can take the
rubik's cube apart
and have all the pieces down and put it
back together but they don't someone can
still
configure the the cube just to have it
all the same colors on yeah
and they're still going to be a good
rubik's cube solver right okay so they
don't have to necessarily
pull every little plastic piece out yeah
i mean i i think that's a really good
analogy
that i had never thought of um but yeah
i think that's true like i really like
and i do think of it in in terms of like
being a mechanic
i really like being able to totally
disassemble a story and look at each
little part and go
oh i see what you did there and i see
what you did there and i see how you're
making all of these things work together
and that's really cool
and here's the one thing that's that's
knocking
right or that's like i'm actually not a
car person but here's the one thing that
is
making that funny noise so let's look at
that and maybe talk about
why um the choice that you made
isn't as strong as it could be or is
getting in the way of something else or
whatever it is right
so um so i like to be a story nerd
because i
i just enjoy it um and i think that i
can
sometimes i can help other people
understand
the one little area that they might not
be fully understanding
by bringing that to them but i don't
think every writer needs to be able to
you know understand every single every
single thing that we've talked about
today
you